- The light emitted by
high-intensity-discharge
car headlights are very
effective in activating
the reflective paints of road markers,
thereby making driving at night safer,
and maybe we have no error.
So let's just think
about this a little bit.
What's the subject here?
Well, the subject here
is the light emitted by
high-intensity-discharge car headlights.
Now is this a singular
subject or a plural subject?
Well, we're really just
talking about the light.
We're talking about the light,
and then they tell us what type
of light, the light emitted
by high-intensity-discharge
car headlights.
So the light is clearly singular.
When you read the entire subject,
you might get a little
confused because it ends
when you're talking about
emitted by high-intensity-discharge
car headlights.
And you see that headlights,
your brain might be saying,
you know, maybe this is plural.
But remember, we're really
talking about the light,
and this whole part that
I'm underlining in green
is really just describing
the light that we're talking about.
So the subject is really
a singular subject.
So the verb that goes with
it also needs to be singular,
but if we look at underlined
part A right over here,
are is not the singular version of is.
It's the plural version.
So this right over here is plural.
It should be singular.
And to really test why this sounds strange
or why this doesn't make sense is,
ignore this green part right over here
and just test it out that way.
If I just said, the
light are very effective,
that makes no sense.
I have a singular subject
with a plural verb.
So this has to be a singular verb.
It has to match the subject.
This is much better.
The light is.
Singular subject, singular verb.
The light is very effective.
So the error is in part A.
This are should be an is.